Sean McGinnis here with a GS news update
Palmer Luckey CEO of oculus the company
behind the oculus rift has discussed his
vision for the text future according to
lucky traditional TV and monitor
displays will disappear over the next 10
to 20 years and the tech will move far
beyond playing video games lucky sees VR
becoming the direct link between all
people and media it's like a Facebook
for example completely envelop your
world during an interview at PAX East
this past weekend lucky said virtual
reality it can't just be a visual thing
if via remains a visual only thing then
certainly will never replace human touch
based interactions it sounds like
touch-based interactions are part of the
plan then the interviewer also asked
lucky about the potential for oculus
rift to make people feel isolated by
encouraging them to replace real-life
social interactions with virtual reality
video calls lucky said physically
isolated maybe but I don't think
socially isolated if anything I think VR
is one of the most potentially
connecting technologies we have out
there I guess you'll have to ask
yourself why do we care if we're
physically isolated if we're mentally
connected if you can perfectly simulate
reality why do you need to actually go
see people in real life these comments
come just after Facebook surprised two
billion dollar acquisition of oculus VR
last month and lucky seems to have put a
lot of thought into the ways VR can
affect social interactions for more on
virtual reality and Palmer Lucky's
slightly dystopian view of the future
stay tuned to gamespot com
you